-The crowded 2020 field
got another addition today
when Beto O'Rourke jumped in,
and President Trump
immediately attacked him.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump and his advisers
are already putting together
his 2020 re-election campaign,
and they're not just staffing up
and raising money.
They reportedly
want Trump's re-election bid
to be one of the biggest
and most sophisticated campaigns
in history.
Trump's campaign manager told
"The Washington Post" this week,
"We are creating
the largest campaign operation
in American history.
An unstoppable apparatus
that will follow and implement
President Trump's strategy."
An "unstoppable apparatus"?
[ Laughter ]
Are you talking about
your presidential campaign
or the Death Star?
[ Laughter ]
But, of course, Trump has to
create an unstoppable apparatus
because he's, perhaps,
the weakest candidate
of any sitting President
in recent history.
Polls have shown that
a large majority of Americans
consider the President
both a criminal and a liar.
And yesterday, the guy who ran
the President's last campaign,
Paul Manafort,
was both sentenced in one case
and indicted in another.
Trump was asked by reporters
if he was considering a pardon
for Manafort,
and he insisted that he wasn't.
-Will you pardon Paul Manafort?
-I have not even given it
a thought as of this moment.
It's not something
that's right now on my mind.
-Now, in fairness,
that's an accurate answer
to virtually any question
you could ask Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. President..."
[ Cheers and applause ]
For example, "Mr. President,
what is the role of government
in American life?"
"It's not something
that's on my mind."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's brain
is capable of holding
exactly one thought at a time,
and it echoes through
his skull like a cave.
-[ Echoing ] Hamburgers,
hamburgers.
China, China, China.
Golf, golf, golf.
-But the Russia investigation
and the various scandals
swirling around Trump
aren't the only things
making him vulnerable.
In fact, this week,
he did something
that could potentially hurt him
more politically
than Robert Mueller ever could.
He proposed a budget
that would gut
wildly popular
healthcare programs
that he specifically promised
he would never cut.
-President Trump released
his budget for 2020 today,
proposing massive cuts to
government-funded healthcare.
The President's budget
includes a cut of $845 billion
to Medicare
over the next 10 years
and $241 billion from Medicaid.
-So, Trump said he would
never cut Medicare or Medicaid,
and now he's cutting billions
from Medicare and Medicaid.
Is there anything about this guy
that isn't a lie?
I'm starting to suspect
his fake hair
is covering a full head
of real hair.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's legal attacks and his
attacks on healthcare programs
have made him one of
the weakest incumbent presidents
in modern polling and left
a huge opening for Democrats,
which is why so many of them
are running for president.
In the last few weeks,
Washington governor Jay Inslee
and former Colorado governor
John Hickenlooper
have officially jumped in.
Colorado Senator Michael Bennet
was in New Hampshire,
and New York City mayor
Bill de Blasio
was in South Carolina,
and Senator Elizabeth Warren
was in Queens,
and three more candidates
were in Texas
doing townhalls on CNN.
In total, "The New York Times"
lists 15 candidates
who've already declared
and at least another eight
who might run.
Look at that.
There are so many people
on that screen,
you didn't even notice
that one of them was Carrot Top.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And on top of all that,
"The New York Times" reported
that former Vice President
Joe Biden
is 95% committed to running,
and in this speech
to firefighters this week,
he teased --
[ Cheers and applause ]
he teased a possible run.
-You know,
I'd like you all to --
I appreciate the energy
you showed when I got up here.
Save it a little longer.
I may need it in a few weeks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Be careful what you wish for.
-No, dude,
be careful what you wish for.
You really want to do this?
If you run for president,
everyone's gonna dig
through every dumb thing
you've said the last 40 years
and get mad at you.
Why do you wanna
do that to yourself?
Right now, you're known
as Obama's wingman, Uncle Joe.
The only guy who ever looked
like he was having fun
at the State of the Union.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean,
look at that party animal.
He looks like
right after that was over,
he was gonna make Obama
do a keg stand.
[ Laughter ]
Then, there's former Texas
Senate candidate Beto O'Rourke,
who officially jumped
into the race today
after spending weeks
teasing a possible run.
Beto appears on the new cover
of "Vanity Fair" this week
with the headline
"Beto's Choice."
And, look, I'm a little upset it
took Beto this long to announce,
because if he'd done it in 2008,
I definitely
could've played him on "SNL."
[ Laughter ]
Definitely.
I mean, it certainly was closer
than John Kerry.
[ Laughter ]
But the cover was not
the only eye-catching thing
about this profile.
Beto also explained why
he wanted to run for president.
Now, it's a key question
for any candidate.
People want to know
why you're doing this
and what you can bring
to the table.
It's a question
past candidates have flubbed,
and, in many cases,
it's doomed them.
So, here's what Beto said.
"I think I'd be good at it.
I want to be in it.
Man, I'm just born to be in it."
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry.
No one is born to be president.
Nobody is born to be anything.
Springsteen said
he was born to run,
and then he wrote
400 songs about New Jersey.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at Trump.
He wasn't born to be president.
If he was born to be anything,
it was selling fake Rolexes
in Times Square.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Beto also talked
about his rise to fame,
the Senate campaign that
launched him to national stardom
and the very first event
he did in that campaign,
and his description
of that experience was --
Well, it was a little weird.
He told "Vanity Fair,"
"I honestly don't know
how much of it was me.
But there is something abnormal.
Super normal.
I got in there, and I don't know
if it's a speech or not,
but it felt amazing,
because every word
was pulled out of me,
like by some greater force
which was just the people there.
Everything that I said,
I was, like,
watching myself being, like,
'How am I saying this stuff?
Where is this coming from?'"
[ Laughter ]
Now, in the run-up to 2020,
we here at "Late Night,"
we're gonna try really hard,
and we're gonna ask yourselves,
"Would we make fun of
Donald Trump if he said that?"
So, let's see.
"Because every word
was pulled out of me, like,
by some greater force,
which was just the people there.
Everything that I said,
I was, like,
watching myself being, like,
'How am I saying this stuff?
Where is it coming from?'"
Yeah, no, Beto,
that was [bleep] weird, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was a [bleep]
weird thing to say.
Seriously. I did not know
that weed was legal in Texas.
And when Beto went to Iowa today
for his first official event
since announcing his campaign,
there were
a few more weird moments.
For example,
at the end of his speech,
a lady in the crowd forced him
to make it absolutely clear
that he was
running for president.
-Thank you.
I cannot tell you
how much this means to me.
I will remember this forever --
every single one of your faces
and what you were wearing,
what you had to drink.
[ Laughter ]
-Let us remember it!
Tell us
that you're going to run.
Announce it now for us.
-He already did.
-I'm running to serve you
as President of
the United States of America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Man, I don't know who
that lady is, but I love her.
[ Laughter ]
She should moderate
every presidential debate.
"You have five seconds.
Now spit it out!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And yet as weird as Beto's
launch has been so far,
as always, Trump and his allies
on Fox News
have found a way
to outweird him.
For example,
the "Vanity Fair" profile
mentions some of the books
Beto has in his house,
and Fox News host Brian Kilmeade
was apparently baffled by that.
-"Vanity Fair" has a huge
article and feature on him.
It's almost as if they helped
launch his campaign.
Here's a quote from it.
He says,
"I want to be in it, man.
I'm just born to be in it."
They also point out
that he has this huge library,
as if it's a big plus
that he reads books.
-I mean...
[ Laughter ]
It is a plus.
Reading is definitely...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's definitely a plus
for a president.
Also, just so you know,
when you attack someone
for reading books,
you're really
attacking yourself.
[ Laughter ]
Although I'm not surprised
Kilmeade is anti-book.
I bet if you open one
in his house,
there would just be
a hollowed-out spot
for a Snickers.
[ Laughter ]
"I see you found 'Moby Dick.'
I think you'll find
it's delicious."
[ Laughter ]
And Fox News is not
the only cable channel
that's taken a keen interest
in Beto's announcement.
There was also MSNBC,
which honed in on even
the smallest details
of Beto's trip to Iowa.
For example,
they seemed especially fixated
on his minivan.
-Beto O'Rourke is driving
himself in his Dodge Caravan.
-Where is he?
-And he's arriving here
to Fort Madison High School.
-Yvonne, do we know
how the minivan got to Iowa,
if it's a rental
that he acquired there
or if this is sort of
the O'Rourke family minivan
that has now been moved to Iowa
for campaign purposes?
-It looks like an Illinois van.
This is about three hours away
from any major city.
The question, Congressman,
is where is the rental car from?
-Des Moines.
-Picked it up
in the Des Moines airport.
-Wow.
Hard-hitting stuff, you guys.
[ Laughter ]
"Did you use Hertz or Avis?!
Answer the question!"
[ Laughter ]
"Will you release
your minivan returns?!"
[ Laughter ]
Then there was Trump.
Today, Trump is dealing with
an urgent airline-safety issue,
a resolution from the House
calling for the Mueller report
to be made public,
an unprecedented rebuke
from the Senate
over his national emergency
declaration,
and dozens of scandals
and investigations
of every aspect of his life,
not to mention he was meeting
with the prime minister
of Ireland.
But amid all of that, he just
had to take a swipe at Beto.
-What's your reaction
to Beto O'Rourke's announcement
today, Mr. President?
-Well, I think he's got
a lot of hand movement.
I've never seen
so much hand movement.
I said, "Is he crazy or is
that just the way he acts?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry,
are you accusing someone else
of having weird hand movements
and acting crazy?
Every time
you do a press conference,
you look like you're playing
an invisible accordion.
[ Laughter ]
"You guys ready
for the liars polka?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, Beto is jumping into
a crowded field
that already has several
established candidates
who have spent weeks
laying the groundwork
in early primary states,
like Bernie Sanders,
who was in Iowa last week.
And when he mentioned
climate change, this happened.
-Tonight, we say to Donald Trump
and the fossil-fuel industry...
[ Crowd booing ]
-[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well...
That is
one way of phrasing it.
[ Laughter ]
I, myself, was gonna say it
a little bit differently.
I am a senator, you know.
-Man, you could just tell
from his face
that he wanted to say it.
[ Laughter ]
And it would make things
a lot more entertaining
if Bernie
was just totally unleashed.
Can you imagine
how much bleeping
they'd have to do on C-SPAN?
-Donald Trump
is a [bleep]...
[ Laughter ]
...and a [bleep]
-Now, some of these candidates
are more well known than others,
but one lesser-known candidate
who seems to be gaining
a lot of traction this week
is Pete Buttigieg,
the mayor of South Bend,
Indiana.
Buttigieg got rave reviews
for his performance
at a townhall on CNN on Sunday
where he said this
about Vice President Mike Pence,
who was previously
the governor of Indiana.
-How could he allow himself
to become the cheerleader
of the porn-star presidency?
-And that is
such a great analogy,
because this presidency
is definitely like a porno.
And Pence might be able to tell
himself he's not the star,
he's not the one having sex,
he didn't take his clothes off,
but he's definitely the guy
watching through the keyhole.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats are eager
to take on Trump
because he's
the weakest incumbent President
in recent history --
he's beset by scandals,
and he's gutting Medicare,
and on top of that,
voters are looking at Trump
and asking themselves...
-Is he crazy or is that
just the way he acts?
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]